OK.
This is not the most important story of the
day, but it is one of those.
If they're lying about this, what else are
they lying about?
Types of stories, not this past Friday, but
the one before it was reported that Donald
Trump was brought down to the bunker below
the White House for his safety.
And this is is not actually something to laugh
at.
These are decisions Secret Service makes about
the safety of the president.
But Donald Trump kept tweeting and acting
like a big man and some started pointing out,
you know, big, tough Trump won't go near the
protesters and instead tweets from the safety
of his basement bunker.
So Trump was triggered by this.
He came out and he denied that he went to
the bunker for safety reasons.
He said, oh, I did.
I decided I wanted to go down and inspect
the bunker on that particular day.
This was what he told Fox and Friends a few
days after the incident.
We don't know.
Leland Verrett Vittert reporting.
No problem.
We got dark.
Huge problem.
He was attacked and then the reports were
there were so worried they brought you downstairs
in the White House to a bunker.
What could you tell me Sunday night?
Sunday night was like for you and your family?
Well, it was a false report.
I was down I went down during the day and
I was there for a tiny little short period
of time and was much more for an inspection.
There was no problem during the day.
The problem I saw, Leland got whacked pretty
good, but that was during the night.
And this problem, these problems are during
the night, during the day.
And I go down.
I've gone down two or three times.
All for inspection.
And you go there someday.
You may need it, but you go there.
And I went down.
I looked at it.
It was during the day.
It was not a problem.
And I read about it just like a big thing.
There was never a problem.
We never had a problem.
No, nobody ever came close to giving us a
problem.
The Secret Service does an unbelievable job
of maintaining control in the White House.
Right.
Trump claiming that he regularly inspects
the bunker for no other reason than, I guess,
to make sure that it's up to his construction
standards.
So this was obviously not true when he said
it.
But now, hilariously, Donald Trump's own attorney
general, William Barr, said no Secret Service
recommended Trump go down to the bunker.
This is from yesterday.
It was a Fox News interview with Bret Baer.
And Barr doesn't even pretend.
He just admits to the entire thing.
And the context was Barr defending just how
dangerous it was last Monday when protesters
had to be cleared with gas and and horses.
And Barr saying, you know, it was so crazy
that we had to have that Secret Service recommended
Trump go down to the bunker.
A lot of talk about Monday, kind of reliving
the moment there in Lafayette Park.
If you had to do Monday over again, would
you do something different based from what
I know now?
Now.
On Monday, we were reacting to three days
of extremely violent demonstrations right
across from the White House.
A lot of injuries to police officers, arson.
Things were so bad that the Secret Service
recommended the president go down to the bunker.
We can't have that in our country.
Oh, okay.
So Secret Service did recommend Trump go to
the bunker because Trump said he was inspecting
it on what just happens to be the same day
that Secret Service recommended that he go
go down there.
So I don't want to beat a dead horse.
We all knew Trump was obviously lying when
he said he was inspecting the bunker.
But the reminder is, if he lied about this,
what else is he willing to lie about?
And the answer is everything.
He's willing to lie about everything.
Now, just to warn you, at some point the defense
is going to come out and they are going to
say, bah never said Trump went to the bunker
because of the Secret Service.
Barr said the Secret Service recommended from
go to the bunker.
And Trump didn't except to inspect the bunker
on the same day, not because Secret Service
recommended it.
It's nuts.
And it's just, you know, it's one little example
of this.
By the way, I didn't get to this.
But speaking of lying, 10 days ago, Trump
mentioned that he spoke to the Indian prime
minister and the Indian prime minister said
that he was not in a good mood about what
was going on with China.
That conversation never happened.
So just again, the constant lies.
Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi has not
spoken with Donald Trump about the South Asian
nations military standoff with China.
But Donald Trump claimed that a conversation
took place about that.
And Modi was in a really bad mood.
It just didn't happen.
That conversation didn't happen.
So he's lying about the bunker.
He's lying about conversations.
He's lying about everything.
That's the real takeaway.
Don't forget it, OK?